it was the biggest quake japan has ever
recorded
creating devastating tsunami waves
that crashed into towns and communities
along its northeastern coast it left
around 20
000 people dead or missing and it caused
a meltdown at the fukushima nuclear
power plant
that led to more than 150 000 people
being evacuated from surrounding areas
10 years on and just 10 kilometers from
the plant
the town of tomioka still hasn't
recovered
yuta hatakayama was just 14 when he was
evacuated with his family
residents were allowed to return only
four years ago
but parts of the town are still off
limits and strewn with
bags of radioactive soil
they used to hold a cherry blossom
festival here and this road be filled
with food stalls and people
further along the coastline away from
the contaminated areas
lives have been rebuilt and sea defense
is strengthened
the government has turned the
reconstruction effort into a symbol of
national revival coinciding with the
delayed summer olympics
but the games remain in doubt and the
decommissioning of the reactors
poses a challenge for years to come
as of now i think we should keep our
current plan to decommission within the
next
30 years more than a million tons of
contaminated water
has now built up at the site amid
speculation it might be released into
the sea
there's widespread opposition in spite
of government assurances that the water
has been treated
i'm concerned about what will happen to
the fishing industry in the next 10
years
there's talk of releasing the water and
i'm very worried
for many this anniversary will be a time
to reflect on a natural disaster
that took so much from this part of
japan
and that is still dealing with the
legacy of its unprecedented force
rob mcbride al jazeera